um what are you paying attention to what
is concerning to you as it relates to
the conflict internally
um
now and very classically
um there's the emergence of populism of
both sides populism the right populism
of the left
populism means
um that they will fight it and win at
all costs
they're not inclined to compromise
winning is the only thing that matters
and as a result
you have the emergence of this we saw it
with uh the January 6 events
um and
um you could see it more and you have to
ask yourself
how will those be resolved will they be
resolved through compromise and you know
democracy requires compromise
um but you have really greater populism
and greater extremism and um you know it
and it's concerning because a certain
number certain percentage of the
population
um would fight rather than lose and
you're seeing that it's not easy to be
part of the middle you have to pick a
side you know and pick a side and fight
that's always been classically the case
if you look at the
principle or the
Russian Civil War they call him Russian
Revolution but Civil War the Chinese the
Cuban the you know I don't know many of
them
um you have that Dynamic take place so
um
um the working together
to resolve issues
is not likely to
be great
and is is is a big risk